I would have loved for Jamie to fill her
yeah that would have been sweet you
never would he was such a [ __ ] my head
because he was like oh I have to return
and I was so convinced that he was he
was returning to kill oh no way I knew
he's doctors no he's so down I thought
that was romantic get your woman dude
get your [ __ ] woman can I ask you
another question about it last thing I
want to say about it is you think
Brienne and Jaime do you think Breanna
and I found that awkward opposite as
what was I doing I was she was like she
finally got some big what is that
because she finally got dead no I just
thought that they I liked them together
I think I'm not know what she's out
taking her coverage he's a dime piece
it's not gonna work world I believe more
than the drag and get her porn that's
exactly what I'm saying I'm so glad you
said that because I was saying that you
know but all we come on script guard
look so I like when people show skill
even though they're physically not you
know necessarily like or they don't
typically good-looking sushi they like
skill and I think that's so attractive
so if I was Jamie my dick would get so
hard just watching Brienne wield that
sword that's what I'm attracted to
well that I'd be more attractive she was
hot wheeling that sword I know but she
is dating me because of that fact cuz
she said a long time ago like physically
let's be honest physically well it's
like they can [ __ ] is you're admitting I
disagree what you don't smile I'm gonna
tell you again all right your skill
outshine don't sit don't smile because
as in and you he's like you I'm gonna
just by the way you've lucked you've
locked out because a and you know this
I'm not hitting any girl
you're very pretty but this won't last
if you didn't have the personality so
you can also get you know a pretty girl
but you're lucky because she has the
brain right and she has a personality so
that's what you're attracted at the end
of the day is the same you guys aren't
attracted the same thing yes this looks
goes out the window
jay-z's sick of [ __ ] Beyonce you're
right find a pretty girl and I'll find
you a hot guy who's sick of [ __ ] her
but what I'm saying is he's not wrong
because I think that if I were a four I
still truly believe you would date me
and love me and be in love with no I
doesn't be yes no no the only reason is
because you're really hot but it but the
reason why it's been for longevity cuz
your person asked you this now because
you wouldn't got in the door if you're
like if you look like it down there we
go but if you are somehow shut up yeah
we're about to do I love it I think
she's hot too thank you you're so done
with that adults all right hey you two
yeah if she couldn't sing you sure
sparkling be saying that she's a cute
poppy girl barista she looks like one of
those baristas like in Phoenix with a
better face and she can sing [ __ ] you
winged eyeliner she's so key alright
yeah what she's in concert then when she
goes back
it's like crisp are you gonna give a
pound on that what's your fist about
yes no he agreed yeah he agreed
I'll tell you why I'm Tomatoes only corn
Brenda I'm a defender Dell real quick
okay is you can tell the Adel right
sweet person not that sweet person yet
she structurally she has a beautiful
face she what you're seeing is that
she's a little heavier
I like the chicks really I don't
now with kalila I want to say this she
hooked me in with her looks but if she
was in a car accident and then she
looked like Harvey Dent yeah you're out
no I'm in what you was originally the
looks if she looked like she was busted
you'd like great personality would
definitely be friends yeah but you know
what um he has been with really hot
chicks in the past but they'll have
personality it's not this is the first
date I spat inside his mouth and I
backhanded him that's what here's the
thing if you were if you were hideous
and spit in his mouth and backhanded him
you'd be in prison like he's not he's
not inviting you over to the crib press
charges so you think that I get away
with backhanding him because I was on
the first day on the firt the only
reason you got away with when people go
looks don't matter I get that I agree at
the end of the day it doesn't but looks
matter initially initially the looks is
everything does all we know about you
you do that's what Bobby's address I my
sister the other day she was on a plane
and this really fat creepy guy kept
hitting on her daughter does she look
like you and no no my she might my niece
is a very very pretty girl and she was
getting hit on by this like really fat
grotesque man oh yeah and then her mom
was getting really upset like that sick
[ __ ] that sick [ __ ] why would even he
she's like 16 years old and then I was
like well honey that's her name I'm not
kidding I was like honey um what if
griemann what if he was like what if he
look like Brad Pitt Oh he'd be allowed
to stare and it's true like cuz that's
all you know that's all you know about
me be fat die they're creepy when they
don't you know live up to us I don't
think
I don't think there's anything wrong
with that [ __ ] up why is it [ __ ] up
but because we are it's in our DNA to
like pretty things babies when they see
people they are attractive the more
pretty well-defined face it's what that
makes them happy it's not it's not not
my choice I don't like fat girls to my
DNA it's my taste but I met kalila on
tinder and and while I would swipe right
that's exactly so I would I go ugly ugly
long beach she seems real Asian right so
initially you're right she was I have
found her you know what I found her legs
she had a couple of photos of her legs
too that I really liked but it was her
face original her face yeah but then her
legs also with my leg on there there was
no there were pictures of me no what no
what no what happened was I did some
research
yeah - I went onto your like Facebook
away instagram oh of course she did yeah
yeah and Founder physically attractive
yes and it just so happens that you have
a ton of personality and you guys Souls
mesh together she was the first girl I
saw naked right the first girl ever
no the first naked body I've seen since
that down syndrome yeah but what I saw
her naked ice I I've done this before
but rarely where I where I look at the
body and I look up at the heavens and
you realize there's a guy had to go
thank you
me too thank you baby yeah yeah really
happen like twice my let me tell ya but
is that why you ran away midway through
the first time we had sex yeah you ran
he ran was talking like he just got up
yeah that's that's fair yeah it's scary
it's it was like literally like you know
what's it's like it's like getting what
do you mean like you I remember it'd be
so good yeah
imagine playing pong okay in the early
80s right 70s right and all of a sudden
someone gives someone gives you Red Dead
Redemption right after that Oh straight
out right a ps4 like check this yeah
yeah and you're like oh yeah
I don't see why your ps4 I was doing
pong right and some weird like simple
[ __ ] and then she came along I'm like
this is [ __ ] technical yeah right
this is very technical yeah yeah she
kind of
[Music]